les mythes limite est un jeu de société
déconseillé aux moins de 18 ans parce
qu'il contient beaucoup de vulgarité
d'humour noir
si vous êtes mineur ou plus ou moins
facilement choqué je vous conseille donc
de ne pas regarder cette vidéo dans
laquelle tu t'es bien sûr apprendre au
millième degré je ne trouvais rien nous
saluer aujourd'hui on va jouer à les
imiter et mai mais l'élu des élus clé
usb jugent les crimes alors qu'est ce
que c'est limite limite c'est exactement
comme blanc manger beaucoup vous avez
été nombreux à vous demander monsieur
blanc ça va ramer en plus hardcore y
avoir vraiment beaucoup d'humour noir et
de vulgarité
vous êtes jeunes cliquez sur une vidéo
très bien la mienne ça a l'air marrant
mais en fait ça fait mal aux un
changement de trous surprise c'est la
maman mais en fait ça fait mal un membre
de temps 2 cm alors voilà pour les nuls
le livre idéal pour la fête des mères ça
va charrier les mamans alala du funk
font-elles pour les nuls le film les
femmes sont aisne pour les nuls le livre
idéal pour la fête des mères moi j'ai
quand même le mien retrouver son enfant
moche pour les nuls
le livre idéal pour la fête demain donc
utilement la mienne est plus drôle oui
c'est vrai c'est un but incroyable bond
de la première cuillère jusqu'à la
dernière goutte des testicules
trop-plein bon de la première cuillère
jusqu'à la dernière goutte
qu'est ce que tu as à faire mon garde
bloody mary à base de monstration bon de
ne pas la dernière grâce bien dans le
thème du tas je crois que c'est 3-1 non
non je pense que ces 3 1 1 1 me donne
les gaz incontrôlable moi c'est juste
une petite vengeance personnelle
faut que tu te retrouves est un
bourgeois maître gims me donne des gages
incontrôlable mais j'aime bien vite
l'air me donne des gaz incontrôlable
mais celui qui fait le plus d'humour
noir clients non ben là c'est très très
noir comme à la scène et maître gims et
noir aussi oui mais c'est pas drôle mais
c'est pareil pour toi voilà voilà bien
évaluer le risque 3 2 mais c'est vrai
que ce jeu est à ce prix
ouais mais elle est animée mais demande
à ton médecin s'il est bon pour toi
devant la tombe de haut
c'est sympa dont la demande à ton
médecin si les filles qui ne veulent pas
c'est bon pour toi d'abord d'un taux
médecin c'est une grève de pénis ont dit
au revoir à yoann yoannn 4 1 qui ne sera
pas dans son jeu boit pour oublier
je vois pour oublier un porno japonais
avec des tentacules je vois pour oublier
les filles qui mettent les doigts
ultime étudiants portugais venus match
nul 1 1
le fantasme qui étaient mouillés 100%
des bonnes soeurs ok tu comme ancien
drame et jésus vraiment entre deux
hoquets alors je connais bien car
l'hélicoptère devant sa belle
voilà les galets tu crois que ça peut
battre la main droite de jamel le
fantasme qui fait mouiller 100% des
bonnes soeurs ouais y'a nous
actuellement il ya quatre partout c'est
la finale de cette première marche à le
septième jour dieu créa
est-ce que je peux modifier un terme
tant que ça aille avec la phrase s'est
vu comment elle est tournée se dépenser
quoi la phrase non mais c'est un rêve
des pvd son classeur entre lui et son
camarade de collège pour voir si ce côté
là a quitté l'école n'ont pas été à
prendre des leçons a choqué tous
septième joueur dieu créa la catégorie
fat de newport le septième jour je crée
à le blanchissement de l'anus le
septième jour dieu créa se faire
blanchir la nuit bars et la dernière qui
s'avère à le gagner mais je pense et
deuxièmement je te propose d'utiliser là
elle comprend 50 cartes et parmi les 50
on en choisit 9 qui nous font kiffer
c'est parti c'était une carte sa [ __ ]
scandale à clermont ferrand un
instituteur aurait montré à ses élèves
en fait j'avais des bonnes mais j'ai
envie de s'arrêter à ça c'est
intéressant
clermont ferrand annoncé twitter aurait
montré une fissure anale à ses élèves
scandale à clermont-ferrand un
instituteur royal bonbon un instituteur
et montrer un clochard qui s'est
masturbé public à ses élèves un peu long
je préfère me fiche pas mal aux cadres
pour éviter l'éjaculation précoce je
pense souvent à une mamie nymphomane a
raconté jacques relation précoce je
pense souvent à un jacuzzi d'urines 2 0
pour après vingt ans de débats le sénat
a enfin voté l'interdiction dont
d'uriner dans l'aquarium du resto
chinois c'est pas folichon non
après 20 heures de débat le sénat a
enfin voté l'interdiction de sucer après
la sodomie les offres vous étiez bien
couché les séries j'étais petit nos
enfants ont rêvé de devenir pompier
moi ce qui me faisait rêver c'était
d'avoir un vibromasseur modelé sur la
[ __ ] de passe partout quand j'étais
petit les autres enfants rêver devenir
pompier moi ce qui me faisait rêver ses
terres biberons remplis de sperme 3 2
bah je sais que ça mais c'est pas ma
force et ma pioche national geographic
prévoit son prochain documentaire
animalier sur une racaille en mini ski à
courchevel a nagé résolu ces problèmes
quand tu crois que du cul c'est des fois
c'est pas faux mais oui moi je ne crois
pas du tout que je sais c'est qu'à des
jeunes placés écrits critiques alors là
c'est donc un cadeau des qataris ont
investi 30 milliards d'euros pour
éradiquer les asiatiques bien monter un
repreneur d'euros pour juste deux trois
personnes sont un peu fous la value pour
moult raisons le mauvais rôle à moi je
suis là en face de vous j'adore formes
existantes ça me plaît vraiment beaucoup
me matas et franchement c'est
dégueulasse parce que là on rit jaune un
peu comme
olala bien joué à toi pour la sera au
lac est ce que je fais deux casquettes
choc des caisses jardim est ma casquette
à l'envers et pib pour y aller ce couple
qui vient de battre oméga dec
j'ai bien impressionné c'est l'heure de
la finale oui tu peux bouger tellement
tu as quatre ans pour cette finale tout
comme d'un enfant va trouver une carte
avec trois mots alors malheureusement
n'y a pas de carte à trois trous il ya
que deux trous à chaque fois finalement
comme les femmes donc déjà rastelli file
vite les mines mais mais mais alors du
coup on va faire les trois et c'est
celui qui en gagne deux sur trois qui
gagne quand je suis sous j'ai tendance à
confondre mon pénis sans testicules et
un brin d'enfants quand je suis saoul et
tendance à confondre des lasagnes vendu
son cheval et un risotto des mourides
c'est dur c'est vraiment dur futur
franchement à part toi ok ça comme tu
l'as dit elle alors si vos loisirs
c'est une pente dangereuse qui risque de
mener à très bien les noirs c'est une
pente dangereuse qui risque de mener à
la piscine de demain quoi il est quand
même confiant vu de la fédération
française de fist fucking et une pente
dangereuse qui mène une vie peut mener à
la triple pénétration je suis déçu de la
fin voilà homme aux yeux ces labels de
lamelles de l'appel ianu ton père et moi
retrouver 1 1 et 1 1 dans ta chambre
nous exigeons des explications car c'est
bon j'ai mis 20 minutes opératoire à ton
père et moi avons trouvé un porno gay
allemand et un singe qui buzze une noix
de coco dans ta chambre
nous exigeons des explications assez
drôle puisque les objets sur vote de fac
mais c'est pas aux frères et moi avons
trouvé clara morgane et des
sous-vêtements comestibles dans ta
chambre no exigent des explications
la mienne plus haut le plus drôle on
peut faire comme sur la première c'est
les gens qui passent dans le commentaire
mais là vraiment d'être objectif
vraiment des objectifs qui a gagné selon
vous entre ton père et moi vous trouvez
un porno gay et un s'inscrivent et de
noix de coco ta chambre de votre
explication ou alors tomber la voix vous
c'est très très drôle à ton père et moi
avons trouvé des sous-vêtements
comestibles et clara morgane dans ta
chambre qui a gagné c'est à vous de le
dire nous sommes tous on affluence pas
les gens je déclare femme gagne je te
des grammairiens de cette vidéo annonce
des faits une auréole je trouvais déjà
nommé là découlent bon écoute et gentil
apprentissage et à ça vous a plu c'est
qu'il ne s'est pas l'aimer comme
d'habitude n'hésitez pas non plus à le
faire un tour sur la chaîne youtube de
notre amie diane ayasse si j 23 que
jordan 23 son honnêteté
merci yann d'ailleurs de m'avoir à
l'abonné vous abonner ou à vous et vous
tient tout le monde je fais ça par
passion
pis elle répond c'est à voter pour moi